أنا سوزي كراتشي مؤلفة
كتاب طبخ أطباق البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​، ويسعدني
أن أريكم أحد أنواع الحساء المفضلة لدي
من كتاب الطهي المسمى
شوربة السبانخ والحمص بزيت الزيتون البكر
الممتاز ، بداية كل شيء
لذيذ بمجرد أن يصبح الزيت الخاص بك
لطيفًا ولامعًا  تفضل وأضف البصل الخاص بك
[موسيقى]
أربعة فصوص ثوم مقطعة أوه نعم عزيزي
ستصدر تقارير كل شهر يناير
وسيعلن الناس أن أفضل نظام غذائي
لهذا العام هو حمية البحر الأبيض المتوسط
التي نشأت في مصر وكشخص
نشأ وهو يأكل  وبهذه الطريقة ،
كان من الصعب جدًا بالنسبة لي أن
ألتف رأسي حولها مثل قياس
السعرات الحرارية وربما تزن نفسك
كثيرًا ، وهو ما لم يكن حقًا الطريقة التي يعيش
بها سكان البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​على الأقل
حيث نشأت نوعًا من
حياتهم  بالنسبة لي ، لقد قمت للتو
بتلخيص طريقة البحر الأبيض المتوسط
لتناول الطعام في هذه
المبادئ الثلاثة البسيطة التي تتناولها مع المواسم ،
وتستخدم في الغالب أطعمة كاملة ، وقبل كل شيء ،
دعونا نضيف  المزيد من النكهة قليلاً ،
هل أنت مستعد لذلك ، لدينا ثلاث توابل من
الفلفل الحلو والكزبرة والكمون ، أوه ، نعم ،
حفلة نكهة هنا ، وإذا كنت
تحب القليل من الحرارة التي
أفعلها ، فسأدخلها مع رشة من رقائق الفلفل الأحمر
والآن بالنسبة للمكون النجمي
، تم تجفيف علبتين من الحمص
وغسلهما وسنستخدم سائلهما هنا
أيضًا ،
نذهب مع أربعة أكواب من
مرق الخضار هنا إذا كان لديك
مرق الدجاج ، ما
تريده.  مع سائل الحمص المحجوز
هنا
، الفلفل الأسود وسنغلي هذه
الحفلة حتى تغلي ،
اتركها لبضع دقائق ربما من 20 إلى
30. أوه نعم ، لقد توقفت الحرارة الآن لأن
الحمص قد طري قليلاً
ورائحته رائعة هنا نحن  سنذهب مع
بعض السبانخ ،
سنسمح للسبانخ
بالذبول في المرق الساخن الذي قمنا بتقطيعه
لبعض البقدونس لإضفاء السطوع على
الحساء الكامل الذي يحتوي على الكثير من
النكهات الدافئة الآن  نسخ ليمون
يدك للقبض على أي ق
أعشقها واذهب إليها يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
أنا فقط أحب مدى روعة الحساء
وأضيف إليه رذاذًا من زيت
الزيتون ورش بيكورينو رومانا الجيد
يضرب المكان في كل مرة
[موسيقى]